ونتابع هذه الصور المباشره من لندن وقصر
للتحضيرات الجاريه
لتتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث ملكا
لبريطانيا اذا نتابع هذه الصور التي
تاتينا مباشره حيث يتاهب الملايين عبر
بريطانيا وغيرها من دول العالم لمشاهده
هذه المراسم لتتويج الملك تشارلز الثالث
هي احتفالات رمزيه بالطبع تجمع بين مراسم
دينيه ومظاهر القبه والعراق البريطانيه
التي تعود العالم على متابعتها في كل هذه
المناسبات والتي كان اخرها ربما وفاه
الملكه اليزابيث والتي شهدت جنازه مهيبه
جدا تابعها الملايين حول العالم هذا الحدث
الان ياتي بعد فتره لتتويج الملك تشارلز
الثالث الثالث بالتاكيد ستقام هذه باسم في
كنيسه وست منستر يوم غدا
وسيصبح بعد التتويج الملك تشارلز هو
وزوجته الملكه القرينه كاملا الملك رقم 40
الذي يتوج منذ العام
166 اذا بالتاكيد العامه سيسمح لهم
بمتابعه هذا الاحتفال والتتويج وبالتاكيد
سيتوافدون الى لندن منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى للاصطفاف على جانبي الطريق لمتابعه
هذه المراسم التي يدرك البريطانيون
اهميتها هذا التتويج منذ سنوات طويله لم
يتابع احد يعني اكثر من 70 عاما بقيت
الملكه الراحله على العرش وبالتالي ياتي
هذا التتويج بعد جيل كامل لم يشهد تتويجا
رغم ان هذه العمليه عريقه بريطانيا وتمتد
منذ اكثر من الف عام بالتاكيد هذه
الاحتفالات ستبدا غدا
بموكب رسمي ينطلق من قصر باكينغهام اذا
كنيسه وست مونستر حيث سيسمح للمواطنين
الذين سياتون من داخل وخارج بريطانيا
لمتابعتها هناك
من سياتي وجاء من خارج بريطانيا لمتابعه
التتويج لانه هذا التتويج ايضا هو جزء من
السياحه التي تؤمنها بريطانيا رغم كل
الحديث
عن ربما الكلام والجدل الذي يدور حول
تكاليف هذا الحفل الذي ربما تتجاوز 100
مليون جنيه على كل حال لا ارقام حتى الان
مؤكده لكن بالتاكيد بان الحدث مهم وتعول
عليه بريطانيا لتستمر في هذه العادات
والتقاليد لمتابعه
المزيد في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات